after years of hostility Saudi Arabia's
foreign minister is in Iran on an
official visit his meeting with the
Iran's foreign minister comes as Saudi
Arabia is reopening its Embassy in
Tehran seven years after it was closed
the move follows a deal brokered by
China to re-establish diplomatic
relations between the two countries
dorsa debari Jabari joins us live from
Tehran dorsa this is the mirror image
almost of what we saw a few days ago
when the Iranian Embassy was being
opened in Saudi Arabia
well it is and it isn't surreal uh first
the Saudi foreign minister is due to
speak with his Iranian counterparts at a
press conference shortly we expect that
to happen in the next hour here in the
capital but as far as the embassy itself
reopening the building that belongs to
the Saudi government is not reopening
anytime soon and that's because it's
situated on the street that was renamed
in 2016 after that Shia cleric Umar who
was executed which led to the
demonstrations and those demonstrators
storming the Saudi Embassy and the Saudi
government severing diplomatic ties with
Iran at that time so that street name is
still a point of contention now what we
understand for the time being the Saudi
delegation that are going to be working
in Tehran they're going to be working
out of one of the hotels here until we
believe the Saudi government will secure
another building in the capital to use
as their Embassy that's one of the first
things that we understand now the
Iranian government for their part opened
their Embassy in Riyadh on June 6th and
their consulate on the seventh and the
Saudi foreign minister who was in Tehran
he is the first Saudi foreign minister
to visit Iran in 17 years Faisal bin
Farhan is the first official Saudi to
come to Iran since the Iranian severed
diplomatic since the Saudis rather
several diplomatic ties in 2016. we
understand that the two men will be
speaking to the press and will get a
better idea of what we can expect in
this relationship in the coming months
you know this relationship dorsa I think
you'll agree with me contradict me if
I'm wrong is the big story in the Middle
East right now Saudi and Iran very
methodically deliberately building these
Bridges after years of being Arch rivals
how far does this go I mean for both
sides where do they ultimately want to
take this new relationship
while many here believe that there's a
number of factors that have contributed
to the decision on both sides of the
table to come back to having diplomatic
relations now one would be Iran's
economy it's in dire situation the trade
that would bring in with Saudi Arabia as
a result of this reprochement would be
very very big according to the economy
Ministry Ministry they hope to increase
trade with Saudi Arabia to 1 billion a
year it currently is about 15 million
dollars annually since they didn't have
diplomatic relations so there's a big
economic incentive on the for the
Iranians there's also geopolitical
issues at play here there's Iran's
relationship and role in Syria and also
in Yemen these are the two big conflicts
in the region that many are hoping with
this reproachment and both sides having
taken the decision to resume ties will
see see an end to the conflict in those
regions we've seen that mostly in Syria
now many believe this will be the case
in Yemen as well there's also the issue
of the lack of U.S power in the Middle
East Iran sees as an opportunity to
resume diplomatic relations with a power
such as Saudi Arabia the two countries
of one of the two of the biggest
producers of oil in the world and of
course they share a very similar ideas
about how the region should be shaped
and this is going to be seen as an
opportunity for them to plan that out
dorsa Jabari reporting from Tehran thank
you very much